[Music]
Mike good morning what did you think at
halftime you mean about the halftime
performance here about who's know the
game itself I thought it was done I was
over now I thought that scoring the
three points dance to make it twenty one
two three and giving Bill Belichick that
extended 20-minute opportunity to make
some adjustments could give the Patriots
an edge and they forced a three and out
to start the third quarter and I thought
hey maybe they have something going on
here but once it went for 28 to 3 I just
thought as a matter of time before we
packed up and went home so I knew there
was an opportunity I knew there was a
window but I thought the Patriots would
have to score first in the second half
to take advantage of it they didn't but
they still found a way to work it out
Mike speaking of halftime who had a
better performance last night Lady Gaga
or Tom Brady all Tom Brady had a better
performance but I tell you what that was
the best halftime show I've ever seen
it really was I was amazed I was blown
away by it and you know the way that a
political statement was made without a
political statement being made at the
beginning it was it was powerful it was
very very powerful was great to be there
for it and I thought that was going to
be the highlight of the night so the
second half start alright the way the
Falcons handled the clock play calling
eight minutes ago in the fourth quarter
how would you describe that well amazing
unfortunate third one and you drop back
to pass and get the strip sack and then
you got the ball first and ten on the
New England 22 with less than four
minutes to go Julio Jones just makes one
of the great catches in Super Bowl
history the sense of inevitability
immediately filled NRG Stadium that the
Falcons are going to win yeah hey look
the Patriots respectable they got it to
eight points but now it's time for the
toss is result by 11 or 15 and it's over
it's done on the 22 and what do they do
they run the ball once they lose a yard
then comes to sack
then comes the holding penalty and the
next thing you know the Patriots get the
ball back and Tom Brady has a chance to
take them 91 yards and I tell you what I
don't know whether you blame Kyle
Shanahan for calling a bad play whether
you blame Dan Quinn for not telling Kyle
Shanahan no we're not dropping back to
pass
in this situation enough blame to go
around
a blown opportunity from a moment where
it felt like the the Falcons had had won
that game I just I didn't understand it
I kept thinking okay they better not
pass and then he goes back to pass and
I'm going all you have to do is run the
ball three times make the Patriots use a
timeout or two and you have a great
field goal kicker and if you get in
field goal you know just Center it for
him put it wherever he wants it and then
you're going to win the Super Bowl I
thought it was that simple I don't know
why that you would start passing the
ball or continue to throw the ball
against the Patriots who are putting
pressure on you who clearly had changed
their defensive scheme with their
defensive backs they were far more
physical I just didn't understand it at
all like we always hear those cliches
about going for the jugular the knockout
punch we're not going to be afraid to be
aggressive we're going to do this we're
going to go out look there's a point
where you just have to shift from what
we would like to do to you know what
let's just try to win this game I mean
any kid playing Madden will shift into
the mode of hey you know what look at
the clock look how look how far I am
ahead I think I'll take the fuel goal
here and I'll take my chances up by 11
you have to be able to step aside from
that that coach speak that you know the
t-shirts slogan crap not that it's
always crap but in those moments you can
quickly become crap and you just have to
play smart conservative football that
reflects an understanding of where you
are and how close you are to finishing
the job it's not going to Mike Florio
from Pro Football Talk comm I know it
took 50 of these to get to overtime you
weren't pleased with overtime rules and
I know that we're reactionary it is it
it why is it unfair to you well it's
unfair to me and then this was the
argument I made seven years ago after
the Saints go down the field after
winning the coin toss in the 2009 NFC
championship game that both teams should
be guaranteed a possession regardless of
whether a fuel roll or a touchdown is
scored by the team that that receives
the kick to start overtime I don't care
that it's a touchdown
the other team should have an
opportunity to match it and I don't
believe that
the rule change that they put in place
where a field goal on the first tribe
doesn't end the game I don't think that
should apply in the regular season
I don't like it in the regular season I
don't like one team scoring a field goal
the other team scoring a field goal and
then you have five or six minutes left
in sudden death and you may have a team
who does that on a Sunday that then has
to play on a Thursday like the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers had to do against the Falcons
this year I think regular season it
should remain sudden-death postseason it
should be a guaranteed possession for
both teams and if they don't like it
then finish why not just adopt the
college rule I just think there's an
equity is missing here and if I'm a
Patriots fan I would feel better about
this Super Bowl win if I was able to see
my defense clamped down on the Falcons
and keep them from scoring a touchdown
to match with the Patriots had done to
start overtime and wouldn't we all have
wanted to see more football last night I
would have taken me on football so I
think the NFL really needs to think
about revising that rule I don't think
they will but they really need to think
about it yeah I would have just played
another quarter and down let it play out
that way if you wanted to we haven't had
overtime in the Super Bowl until last
night but you know will we have another
one in the next 20 years who knows odds
are probably a very short on that I
can't believe it cook 51 I can't believe
he wanted to get into it turnover time
the future for Jimmy Garoppolo now the
Brady got his job back since he was in
jeopardy losing that the first half so
Brady I think it is firmly secure in
that he will open the season as the
starter right that it right Brady's
opens next seasons to started New
England oh yeah I know your father time
is undefeated right but I don't know Tom
Brady's going to give him a better run
than anybody else ever has sports and if
you're Jimmy Garoppolo you have to ask
yourself do I want to stick around as
the backup to Tom Brady if they offer me
seven eight nine million a year
do I want to wait to become the heir to
Tom Brady and after last night at some
point you want to have a heart-to-heart
Tom say look come on trying to for you
on an iceberg here but at least give me
an idea I've got some career decisions
of my own to make we can play two more
years five more years ten more years
what they're going to be and I think
Brady cares enough about the
organization that he would like to have
you know the phrase we've heard so much
over the past couple of weeks and
orderly transfer
our from one to the next so I you know
whatever Brady is going to do I think he
should tell Garoppolo so Garoppolo can
make a decision and then they're
represented by the same agency which
maybe makes that you know not so
unlikely that that Brady wouldn't be
candid with Garofalo about how long
Brady plans to keep boring server oppelo
can make a good decision about what he's
going to do next
Oh Brady could tell his agent Don we who
that could then pass the information on
to Jimmy grunting he didn't even have to
tell Garoppolo he could tell his agent
who could then tell the drop the source
sources close and tell me the press
conference with the MVP press conference
which is what I said if if you're
looking for a scenario that you want an
uncomfortable feel to it it won't
necessarily be the podium it would be a
Brady won the MVP
well that's ready to start in about two
minutes hear how awkward do you think
this will be well you know I think they
tried to bury the hatchet last night I
think Tom Brady when you throw in the
fact that his mother's been dealing with
an illness for the last 18 months Tom
Brady is all about taking the high road
on this one so I think Tom Brady's going
to do what he has to do to rise above it
because he knows that the real revenge
is coming the first Thursday night of
the season when we now know Roger
Goodell is coming back to Foxborough
he's been invited he took the Italian
grandmother approach that nobody's
invited me back to Foxborough well
Robert crafts already invited him back
so that's when Roger Goodell was going
to hear and Dan he was hearing at last I
don't know how much I think for the TV
but he was hearing last night I said hey
I went to the Super Bowl the first night
of the drafter okay safe travels Mike
great to talk to you as always and
thanks for all your contributions this
year to the program
all right thanks Mike Flora pro football
talk.com
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]